welcome to this video coverage of the
candidates tournament in County Manis
Russia the first round and we look at
the game
andrein against Vladimir kumnick kumnick
being one of the favorites of the
tournament and raen is the lowest rated
player but still he qualified so um he
um is of course
also tough player to face so let's see
andrein having white and he goes for
D4 and uh in fact allows the Nimo Indian
as white which is a slight surprise not
a big
surprise um slight surprise because
andrein is mostly mixing his opening
repertoire of one E4 and D4 Sidelines
and now he's playing a D4 Mainline um
however kumnick is of course um yeah
he's not not um Ultra predictable but
slightly predictable um you can expect
him to play the nimzo and um andrein has
obviously prepared something played
Queen C2 here the classical variation
crom Nick castles
A3 takes and D5 and this D5 move is an
interesting um theoretical development
of recent years it was almost um unknown
in the early 2000s let's say
2003 2002 um this move was um was
basically unknown um or let's say it was
regarded as a possible move but not um
um considered to be so great B6 was the
main move back then and it is still
popular nowadays um this D5 move however
has become popular due to the efforts of
many players one of them is CR Nick he
has played this a number of times but
there are also games by um former world
champion Vish arnard and other strong
GMS one point of this move is that after
the the normal looking move C takes D5
capturing on D5 black is uh not
responding with the obvious move e takes
D5 but um has an has a better
alternative the thing is that after this
why can actually play Bishop G5 which um
transposes um the game into something
that might arise from the Rosen in the
Queen's Indian but where the Knight is
not yet on F3 so this is maybe a
slightly better um position for white
the the fun point is that Knight E4 is a
possibility and this renders C takes D5
um rather unattractive in a rather
well-known game between um Carson and
kumnick queen C2 was played
E5 Bishop F4 Knight C6 black has got um
great quick development look how quick
he gets the Rook on the eal and now
after Knight
F3 kumnick got a nice initiative with
this G5 push and even G4 Knight E5 takes
takes and um here after C5 it was black
who had the initiative Carson really
needed to uh play an exceptionally good
defense to um keep this um game um
within the bounds of a draw this was
played in Moscow
2009 so we see that kumnick has um some
experience with this line um but andrein
didn't take as mentioned it is um not
popular anymore because Knight E4 is
believed to give black a good game
Knight
F3 and takes that's um the way it is
played Queen C4 you need to get the pawn
back and B6 and we now we see the
general idea the justification behind
black setup the White Queen and um in
addition this pawn move one move two
moves three moves and A4 this were four
moves for the bishop pair which is nice
you know if you know the channel I I
like my Bishops um and um well the thing
is it took lots of time and black will
gain a further Tempo with Bishop A6 on
the queen and then will quickly open up
the position he has already castled
while um
white still has
um some things to do before he gets the
king out of the middle yeah Bishop G5
very normal looking move Bishop A6 and
here Queen went to A4 yeah in fact here
in a recent
game Nakamura tried a new idea played
Queen C3 against
kumnick um again again kumnick on the
black side this was played in late 2013
in the world um Team Championship in
antalia
Turkey um in fact Nakamura won won this
game very nice game um um it was like
that just to show what was happening and
now he went for this idea going for the
fianchetto um kumnick um in fact was
very close to equalizing in this game
and probably with some precise moves he
um would have been able to to to
actually really make a draw um you can
be quite sure that he has uh polished up
this um by now and would have been ready
for this move but andrein played Queen
A4
yeah here black um also is able to play
C5 it's also possible move but Queen D7
was kumnick choice and choice and this
is nowadays um also a well-known move we
follow a couple of um earlier games
Queen C2 yeah white does not want to
speed up the development even further
now black is very much ready for a quick
C5 and also note that um it's not so
convenient to get F1 developed here this
bishop if you play G3 Bishop G2 for
instance um you still have E2 to worry
about so you cannot easily Castle after
that and um yeah if you go here it uh it
even costs more time Rook takes you need
to artificially castle and this is just
um very
equal yeah this is why white Retreats
the queen and now um black plays in a
very um logical way went for
C5 yeah you need to open up the position
now you're better developed as black and
if you give white lots of time in this
position he will yeah Prosper with the
Bishops and you need to really um speed
up the course of the game C5 takes and
Rook C8 so intending to get this Rook
into the game
quickly yeah and um it's um a very tough
to find um something for YT I did a
quick review of the the games that have
been played and uh and uh did check it a
bit with the computer there is um really
white has a hard time to prove anything
in this line but as we see he took on F6
now recaptures yeah note that oops sorry
hit the wrong button there if you look
at this after this capture black needs
to recapture you cannot flick in this
move because white can Retreat the
bishop so takes and now Queen E4 this is
um a very direct way of course to play
White um just attacks this Rook here in
the corner and uh yeah forces uh the
issue what should black play now if um
you um really care about this Rook I
mean you you re you react to that in a
passive fashion then white really has
accomplished something for instance if
black would play Bishop B7 just for
argument sake Che we give this check and
play Queen H4 and this is already a bit
annoying because black does not have a
good move to cover F6 yeah you cannot
play Knight D7 the queen is on the
Square so the queen probably has to u to
do the to do the covering and now white
can quite safely grab the pawn and
continue with a pawn up you have have
this also coming
up black must do something um drastic
now he cannot play a passive move Knight
C6 um is is a bit more interesting but
still check we look at
this yeah black needs to always lose
this move and then I'll take this is a
bit bit more interesting as manage than
the one before but still it feels like
um this might not be enough for a pawn
black has a much better solution and uh
kumnick plays it he plays Queen to B5
which looks um maybe a bit strange at
first you are yeah let the Rook left the
Rook on pre on eight but it turns out
that um white cannot take it if you look
at this take here takes here and now we
um see that the Rook here must move you
only have D1 one and then after Knight
C6 the queen is uh trapped rather
typical check type of Queen trap takes
takes yeah and now white white is in
trouble this is hanging how do you
continue if white takes then black
flicks in this
check and can even go for direct attack
this is the big problem it's not just um
yeah a thing of material you you just um
get attacked fiercely here very quickly
you look at this there is this very
funny
resource Rook B3 check mate leads to
direct mate and um yeah white needs to
return now and he's completely uh
paralyzed here black has a big
Advantage so white cannot take the Rook
so great move Queen B5 but um yeah well
it's all it all has been played before
and uh you won't believe who played it
is black right kumnick we still follow a
game from um last year between mamed
yarov who's also in this tournament and
kumnick so it's clear that both players
had all this in their home preparation
and if you look at the time spent
andrein spent one one minute something
kumnick like 7even minutes so um yeah
they both um were not um inventing stuff
here they just um knew what to do
because they analyzed it at
home based on on a on a game that
kumnick had already played so it's not
even a hard guessing game okay it took
on C5 now after B4 yeah white really
needed to do that B2 was hanging so
after this white now played E3 which
makes lots of sense attacking the
queen
and uh yeah it must move to
B7 and um yeah what now this um at first
might look a bit AR awkward because uh
well white U now gets the queen over to
the king side and this happened the
check king move to
f8 and now B5 interesting move um the
thing is if white um plays something
like
that black will take and this not uh not
really helping him so B5 is an
interesting intermediate move it uh
obviously attacks the bishop and it
initiates a tactical sequence now black
uh of course has to take it otherwise
white will just win the win material so
he took
it and Rook B1 and this at first looks
really really strange isn't this bishop
lost in this in this pin here after A6
A4 you really uh might think though but
black can play
F5 and um yeah now the White Queen
obviously has to move and um in this
exact position we on move 21 in this
exact position andrein played the move
Queen to
F4 and um this is in fact a novelty this
is the new move on move 21 in the
mentioned game mid yarov against kumnick
it went Queen H4 and after Queen E4 now
mov um went for a draw you can do that
check with a
check and um then they check check went
for a Perpetual
check in the game as mentioned it was
Queen F4 that was played and now kumnick
plays Queen E4 and this is the the
Tactical resource that um keeps black in
the game you attack The Rook
here and and this is the the tempo
Gainer you need to uh save your Bishop
on
B5 here um like in the mov game and
could have gone for Queen H6 and it's a
draw just the same position but he went
um a different way he took on
e4 F E4 uh one one line I'd like to show
when I first saw that I I thought that
maybe Knight D2 might be an idea but
black can simply take this uh take this
Pawn
white might be able to to scrape a draw
but um it's certainly nothing that
interests wh's very much so he took it
and took on B5 so um temporarily white
is a piece up so black needs to grab the
Knight that is attacked on F3 yeah and
um the next move is certainly the most
testing if white now um yeah let's say
takes here you even uh struggle with
being material down the best move is
just B6 intending B7 with u yeah with a
fork on both Rooks so black needs to
react here only has one move Rook to d8
and now y took on F3 note the time the
time is pretty um precise here they both
spent like um 20 minutes 25 minutes in
kik's case to put those moves on the
board so um it's not like they uh we're
just basically on move four of this game
if you uh counted from the moment on
there was a novelty so
GF and Knight C6 yeah the question now
is what about this Pawn on B6 is this
strong is this weak in fact um it turns
out that um the the following sequence
of moves is almost forced because black
has a simple idea he wants to play
Knight to B4 to block this Rook on the
bile and then round up the pawn and if
uh White is not doing anything concrete
against that he will just win the pawn
and probably the game so white needs to
be quick here he went F4 Knight to B4 as
mentioned Bishop G2 Rook B8 it was
attacked and B7 this is completely
forced otherwise he would just lose the
B Pawn he needs to push it to B7 and
supported by the bishop yeah and now we
see um kik's idea he went Knight
D5 yeah stopping the influence of the
bishop by the Knight and here will
attack the B7 pawn and win it there is
no way for white to save the pawn Rook
C1 was
played Black got this pawn and after
Bishop D5 e D5 the game was ended
exactly here with a draw um it's um
clear that white um will take on on
C5 and um here there there are a number
of ways to to draw the game for um for
both sides it's
um kind of kind of u a case where many
leads many uh roads lead lead to Rome um
Rook Rook B5 is one possible way to draw
let's say Rook
C7 and um black also can always play D4
just to split those pawns and and them
later let's say here and then Rook here
here and you will get the pawns it's
just um a completely dead draw we um we
have here the case of a game where the
preparation of both players um was
basically I guess identical they both
identified that best play leads to a
draw which is uh certainly um okay for
for crck in this case with black you you
you have to accept some some cases where
the opponent is just um able to force a
draw what what can you do and andrein
being
um relatively new in those uh Elite
circles he has not played so many of
those uh big tournaments um for andrein
I guess it was also okay to to get this
get this draw and maybe um it's not like
he's sitting there and and wants to make
a draw from move one it's just um the
case that he he knows that the line that
he is choosing he has the draw as um as
the the minimum result he knows that
best play is a draw and if black is
doing something funky he might get some
chances but um it's still um yeah it's
still um not too exciting to to watch to
um yeah to to players um basically
reproducing their analysis but it is
happening in some in some sharp Lin so
not much that you can do about it um
yeah still maybe you got something from
this game it's an interesting line for
black um nevertheless if you um don't
mind to um accept those um type of draws
that that might happen against a well
prepared player then you have a good
line here for the black side and the
nimso Indian all right thanks for
watching